foreign
Eyes Only emergency access
the following file is banned from all
access at any clearance level and
quarantine from the SCP database
access to this page is to only be
attempted by the department of one in
the event of contingency when being
called into effect
if you are not a member of the
Department of one stop reading
immediately and close this page now
by opening the file below you will
immediately activate contingency 1 and
understand the ramifications of such a
process this process cannot be reversed
for any reason by nature of your
position you have been granted access to
trigger contingency 1 without the need
for overseer Council oversight it is
trusted that you are aware of the
circumstances requiring a contingency
one activation and will not access this
page early or without proximate and
urgent need
proceed with this action a button only
visible to you will permanently unlock
the contents of this file
item number scp-6511
object class thumbia
special containment procedures
you are to read this document and follow
the instructions Within
description
scp-6511 is a series of emergency
protocols causing the intentional and
near complete removal of the SCP
Foundation and its constituent
components from reality
scp-6511 is this page and all
instructions and information within it
which acts as the outward manifestation
of these protocols
do not stop listening
the mechanism allowing for the existence
of scp-6511 are inherently encoded into
all people objects and Concepts adjacent
to the foundation the utilization of
scp-6511 is dependent on the activation
of contingency 1. a mechanism
exclusively keyed to the foundation
Department of one please note that
scp-6511 is only to be used in a
scenario where the foundation's
continued existence is a threat to
itself and to established reality
the department of one was created as
part of initial formulation of scp-6511
it is unique in that it consists of a
single individual which acts as its
entire staff at any and all points in
time the death of a department of one is
immediately followed by the appointment
of a replacement and only one can exist
at a time the current Department of one
is to be isolated from the vast majority
of foundation operations and not to be
given additional duties Beyond those
granted by their Department membership
the preservation of the Department of
one is to be insured at all costs
if you are listening to this version of
the document you possess Department of
one clearance in a scenario where
scp-6511 protocols must be executed it
is currently your responsibility to
activate the mechanism neutralize the
threat and restore the SCP Foundation by
the nature of the consequences of
activating scp-6511 it is unknown how
much of this or any other information
you will retain following the activation
potential threats that may require the
activation of scp-6511 are by the nature
of this protocol almost entirely unknown
and not understood there is very little
information available to prepare the
department of one for their Duty apart
from that which resides in this document
the success of the Department of one in
restoring the foundation is dependent
almost entirely on factors outside of
the foundation's control for these
reasons scp-6511
should only be activated in cases where
any other option would result in the
destruction of the SCP Foundation or
worse
the origins and creators of scp-6511 are
currently unknown similarly the record
of contingency 1 activations is also
unknown although inconsistencies in
historical records of the foundation
suggest possible reference points by
virtue of your position you are also
believed to have knowledge of the
scp-6511 activation record that is not
available to any other member of the
foundation however this suspicion has
never been confirmed by you or any of
your predecessors
if you have reached this section of the
file contingency 1 has already been
activated continue listening for further
instructions
do not stop listening under any
circumstances
the department of one which is yourself
is a division of the foundation that
exists entirely outside of its sectional
hierarchy it is imperative that you
understand the full responsibilities of
the Department of one before you are
forced to begin them shortly
foreign
you are not safe here the SCP Foundation
has for nearly the entirety of its
existence enjoyed the position of
reigning Warden over the anomalous world
if not the World At Large itself
it wields nearly unlimited political
financial and physical power to the
point that opposition to our goals is
easily understood confronted or managed
through the employment of the resources
at our disposal we have weathered many
storms and come out relatively intact we
are tempted to view ourselves as the
apex predators of the anomalous world
however the greatest misconception of
the average Foundation employee is that
this does not mean we are invincible
imagine it being with the traits of a
perfect Predator a being that can match
its praise every move carrying all
attacks and breaking every defense
knowing exactly where it is at all times
these beings are the ultimate liability
for the foundation a sufficiently
powerful organization entity or other
unknown force with the ability to
relentlessly completely and instantly
fix upon targets without needing even
its knowledge is the only unbeatable
threat to the foundation it will run it
will follow it will shake off and adapt
to our every attempted attack but we are
paralyzed so resiliently stable so
swelled with our own power that nothing
can stop the inevitable point where it
finds our neon sign and pounces
when an entity is rendered Ray it
essentially has two options fight or
flight direct confrontation to
neutralize the threat or simply evading
it until it is eventually shaken or
alert away but the perfect Predator is
unfazed by either it will keep stalking
you never running out of energy or
resources no matter how far you go and
when you least expect it it will destroy
you in an instant leaving no Trace no
time for you even to scream Evolution
will create such beings ideal survivors
feeders lurking in every corner of the
anomalous World Perfect Defense is
nothing to the perfect predator in the
face of such an entity the only
creatures that have a chance to survive
are something entirely new a perfect
Hider something with the ability not
just to run but to disappear the
ultimate form of playing dead to die for
so long that the hunter that has marked
it will grow bored of the chase wither
away or even die it is a waiting game
and for the entirety of that game you
must never ever be found
if the foundation has made the Quarry of
this hypothetical being it must hide
these entities are real the department
of one Protocols are engaged when the
SCP Foundation is targeted by such a
predator
the origin of this text is unknown
the activation of contingency 1 and the
opening of this file implies that such a
threat to the foundation has been
identified not only this but this threat
is here present and further existence of
the foundation in its current form is no
longer possible if this file has been
opened the entity that has caused the
activation of this iteration of the
Department of one has already detected
the foundation it is impossible to say
how close it is to seeing you
the protocols that you are responsible
for are the process by which the SCP
Foundation its history and record of
existence and its knowledge as a concept
are changed into a vastly different form
that allows for it to remain undetected
and absent from the world for an
indefinite extended period of time they
are strictly only to be employed when
all other options of dealing with an
existential threat to the foundation
have been exhausted and it is decided
that the destruction of the foundation
is preferable to the alternative
the department of one is the Fail-Safe
that is attached to this act of
self-destruction its duty is to reverse
the restructured reality and return the
foundation to normal existence when the
time is right
the department is the Sentinel
torchbearer that watches the threat for
as long as it can that holds the key
that resurrects the foundation from its
long and deep sleep they are the sole
remaining employee of the foundation
during these periods the key to unlock
the shallow coffin
you are the designated survivor of the
SCP Foundation
as if you're listening to this text the
SCP Foundation has been dissolved
effective immediately unlocking this
secure page and connecting it to the
main SCP database has released a rapid
affecting computer virus that is
designed to circumvent all our Aisa
firewalls and lock the entirety of the
foundation's operating servers reality
must be prepared for the change and the
lights are going out one by one
you are currently the only remaining
employee of the foundation you will
receive no further contact or
communication from any other member from
the foundation including the overseer
Council as it no longer exists your sole
directive is to ensure the survival of
the foundation by any means necessary
if you have reached this section of the
file the current operational state of
the foundation has been saved and
encoded in a secure location
continue listening for further
instructions
these are the instructions for the end
of the world
you are to watch as the foundation
crumbles and turns into Ash before your
eyes you are to feel the world shrink
around you collecting every last trace
of that which must not be seen and
hiding it away until the only remains
are empty space you will feel the taste
of every fragment as it breaks away from
the hole
you're to stand in the midst of the
space
you are to ignore the dark creeping in
at the edges of your eyes
you are to wait until it reaches you and
the borders of unreality nip at your
skin you will know that all is finally
locked away
you are to close your eyes so that you
can remember the shape and texture of
the SCP Foundation in your hands you are
to burn the image of its disintegration
into your brain so that when you find
yourself forgetful on the other side of
the door you will still see us in your
dreams
you are to be responsible for the end of
the SCP Foundation
you are to attempt to not cry out as the
rapidly cascading reality finally
shatters onto your body
you will fail
remember what you say
you are to awaken in a world that has
never seen the foundation in a life that
you have always lived you are to try and
remember
you are to be followed by an enemy which
takes a form that is unknowable you are
to be hunted to the death you are to try
and remember
you are to avoid death or destruction
you are to survive as long as is
necessary until you understand
how the threat is to be neutralized
you are to try and remember
you will wait you are the prisoner of
time
you will watch just as it watches you
you will find a way to revert the
changes in reality only when it is safe
to do so you must determine when safety
is guaranteed you are to bring back the
SCP Foundation from a world where it
does not and has never existed we cannot
tell you how this is done
we do not know
we have never known
you are to become one
if you have reached this section of the
file the foundation's physical and
informational structure has now been
crippled Beyond regular function to
conclude the CK class reality
restructure continue listening and
follow the instructions
you are to read your eulogy
there is a dead tree just outside your
window where the last traces of the
foundation lie you stand in the remnants
of a shattered form you breathe in its
ashes every time you inhale
walk to it
you are responsible for the continued
survival of the SCP Foundation and the
consensus reality that is tied to it you
have always been responsible since the
day you were selected and told you were
the department of one and told that your
only job was to sit there and live and
waste away until you received a secure
message telling you to find this file in
the database and open it you thought you
would never receive that message that
they all had forgotten about you because
it was their job to you are not told
that this was always to be your final
resting place and that this was decided
the moment you became what you were
in one sense you are the only one that
will remain alive past the break in
reality in another you are the only one
that will die everything else in this
reality will be effortlessly restored
when you return with your mission
complete they will not know that for a
Time indefinite they did not exist and
never existed it is your responsibility
to know that you destroyed them all and
then you will forget you die when you
forget that you live this life in the
first place you will forget your entire
life
the world you were a part of the words
that are written on this page the audio
contained within this document that's
the one catch in the plan we've never
been able to figure out
you are now alone in a dead reality you
have received all the documentation for
your role as the department of one
there is no other help to give
the file has run out
you will leave everything behind you
lived a good honorable life
watch the tree carefully
proceed to the designated location this
file will be the only one left online
listen to the very end of this file
you are not safe here
but the foundation will be
you have reached the end of this file
contingency 1 is now complete to execute
all scp-6511 protocols find a resting
place you will be woken momentarily
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Dr felryn
Wesley clay
tomothy
zargaron
Professor Puffer
broken sketch
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Spencer J telp
well rimmer
vinyl
gavios the hollow
zazapan
lamke
Dr Briggs
tailored printers
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
Lyndon B Johnson
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
and NJ vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you
[Music]